respect it's something that I feel has
been lost lately I even feel like the
definition of respect has been muddied a
bit because people have a tendency to
apply it only to accomplishments that
they feel are worthy of praise and
admiration but I'm talking about respect
on a basic level even if you just boil
it down to common human decency it's
being lost
the golden rule still applies you still
need to treat people the way that you
want to be treated and you're seeing it
less and less these days because people
have an automatic tendency to assume
that if someone is disagreeing with
someone they are their enemy and they're
inherently bad and they should be fault
but you can disagree with someone and
still respect them you can even hate
someone you can hate and abhor their
actions they've doing that they're doing
terrible things and they need to be
hated but you still need to treat them
with respect and that's hard and you may
even be thinking like how can you do
that that's not possible if they're
terrible person they deserve to be
treated unfairly and that's not the way
that I want to live we're all humans and
either we are all humans that are equal
and deserve to be treated as equals or
were not and I know people are probably
going to think that I'm speaking to
generally about this so I want to get
specific I'm talking about this because
of the frenzy that's surrounding Felix
not PewDiePie Felix and I want to be
very clear about something Felix is not
an anti-semite and Felix does not
advocate hate and I'm not even defending
the jokes that he made because even he
has apologized for some of
jokes that he did but he as a person as
an inherent human being he's not these
labels because it's so easy to label
someone it's so easy to do it's so easy
to boil someone down to a single word or
a phrase and that's all they are even if
you're praising them I mean normally
it's when you're demonizing them but
even if you're praising them even if
you're putting someone on a pedestal or
if you're calling them human scum and
trash and garbage you're inherently
dehumanizing them in both aspects and
that's something that I will never stand
for never because I've said it a million
times over and over I repeat this all
the time
we as youtubers are the exact same as
you were humans were people wandering
this world trying to figure out who we
are just the same as you and even though
someone like Felix is being attacked and
he's a lightning rod for hate whether or
not that's a fault of his own actions or
the society that we live in that doesn't
matter to me
because what I'm talking about is the
most basic human element the one rule
that I know very deep down is that we
are all equal and deserve to be treated
with respect
we're more than our labels I don't give
a [ __ ] what the color of your skin is I
don't care what religion you believe in
I don't care where you've come from or
where you are now all I care about is
who you are and whether or not you're
free to be able to discover that and I'm
not even just talking about Felix now
I'm talking generally because if we're
ever going to be more than we are right
now as a society as people as a species
as planet Earth if we're ever going to
be more than
man we need to at the most basic level
respect each other
I miss hard it's hard to take the high
road it's a lonely road no one wants to
go that way because it's so easy to seek
vengeance or apply the other rule an eye
for an eye or label someone as a simple
word or phrase just to dismiss them and
I know people are going to even twist my
words people are going to say that I'm
defending the wrong people or I'm
defending bad people or I'm I'm
spreading hate indirectly because I
support other people that's not the way
I see the world I see each and every one
of us not defined by our race or our
Creed but each and every one of us a new
opportunity to find ourselves and in
order to defend that I have to advocate
the treatment of everyone as an equal if
you don't have that what's going to
become of us what's going to happen in
50 years
when the generations that follow us look
back and see that their forefathers were
too afraid to treat each other with the
most basic level of respect I believe I
believe very firmly that every single
person in the world has the ability to
do something amazing or terrible to
spread love or hate and whether or not
they do one or the other depends on us
depends on us being strong enough to
take the high road in the face of the
worst adversity I have so much hope for
people
I have so much hope for this world and I
have so much hope for what we can do to
make it a better place and that's
something that I will defend to the
death when it comes to dehumanizing
someone or anyone I won't answer that
because at the end of the day there's
going to be people that follow us and
it's up to you and me to show them what
respect really means